what's going on guys welcome to the next
part of our standard deviation tutorial
series here or miniseries where we left
off who are actually calculating
standard deviation now we need to go
ahead and actually just plot it on up if
you don't already have the sample code
it is on link in the description and
just make sure you come highlight all of
it
let's do a nice copy and we'll paste it
in here now where we edit this code that
I made like two little common in spots
where you can start in the code to make
it real nice and easy
and that's where we're gonna be doing
our coding so it added to the chart it's
actually pretty simple we're going to
make a quick little function here called
define standard deviation and then TF
for time frame of that standard
deviation SD for standard deviation will
be an empty array SD date same thing
empty array X for our starting planet
we'll start at time frame whatever that
is while X is less than the length of
the date but we're going to go ahead and
do is say array to consider is going to
be the closed price of X the index value
of x to the index month
value of x - time frame - the actual
value of x so that would be the full
array of data to consider then stand EV
is going to be array to consider dot STD
for standard deviation that is built
into Python it's not something we've
done so the next thing that we want to
do is the dot append stand-up then we're
going to do SD date that append date
it's and we'll go ahead and run our X +
equals 1 and when this is all done
return s just returned SB date as the
and that's really it that's all we have
to do with our standard deviation
equation so that we need to scroll down
a little bit here and do STD as the y
equals
their deviation I will do it 10 for now
well just doing a x2 dot a lot as they
and as the animal color white that's
really it
so now we can save that run that pick
whatever stock you want and plot that up
so here's an example of eBay I'm
plotting the standard deviation of eBay
another good one to do is a Apple a p.m.
remember Apple so as you can see has
Apple you know is steadily rising it was
getting a little bit more volatile than
it really got volatile here and volatile
here and you can see that and so anyway
that standard deviation now we can
resume back to our alphabetical order
and you start doing on the Bollinger
Bands as always thanks for watching
things for all the support in the
subscriptions and until next time